dans les deux dernières vidéos on a vu
que le futur de nos sociétés dépendez
fortement du taux de reproduction
effectif qu'on note rtl qui correspond
au nombre de personnes qu'un individu
infecté à l'instant t contaminent en
moyenne en particulier à moins d'avoir
rt inférieur à 1 de déconfinement
conduire à une seconde vague qui nous
contraindra probablement un second
confinement or un confinement prolongée
ou répétée semble très dangereux car ils
exercent des pressions inédite sur nos
économies et notre système politique y
compris le risque d'effondrement qui
pourrait conduire à des guerres et des
catastrophes
il semble donc y avoir un enjeu énorme à
garder perte est inférieure à 1
malheureusement on ensuite vu que pour
garantir art est inférieur à 1 sans
confinement
la distanciation sociale et les gestes
barrière ne suffiront probablement pas
même une quarantaine de tout individu
symptomatique sera probablement
insuffisante notamment en france où la
population semble moins disciplinés que
dans des pays asiatiques qui peine déjà
à maîtriser la pandémie des mesures plus
efficaces mais aussi possiblement plus
contraignantes semble requises pour
espérer un déconfinement partiel et
sécurisé en particulier avait enfin on a
parlé d'une technologie probablement
indispensable pour un déconfinement
sécurisés à savoir le contact trading
électronique étant donné un individu
testé positif à la coved 10,9 le contact
racing consiste à identifier les autres
personnes avec lesquelles cet individu a
été en contact pour les alerter et leur
demander de se confiner à leur tour
voilà qui critiquent notamment pour
alerter des individus à risque avant
qu'ils n'aient eux mêmes des symptômes
pour qu'ils se mettent eux mêmes en
quarantaine avant de devenir contagieux
oui car de façon très pernicieuse la
copie de 10,9 semble très contagieuse y
compris avant que l'individu infecté né
des symptômes on parle de contamination
près symptomatique qui selon ses
différentes études semblent représenter
près de la moitié des contaminations
d'ordinaire pour contenir des pandémies
le contact racing se fait par
l'interrogation des individus testés
positifs cependant surtout pour une
pandémie comme lakovic 19 cette méthode
est lente coûteuse en travail humain est
imparfaite à cause de la mémoire
déficiente de nous autres non
le contact précise manuel ne suffira
probablement pas à garder art est
inférieur à 1 pour effectuer un contact
racing rapide peu coûteux et efficace de
nombreux chercheurs ont proposé
d'utiliser nos smartphones pour stocker
les informations des autres téléphones
avec qui on a été en proximité physique
ou être plus précis on pourrait ainsi
parlait de contact racing électronique
par opposition aux comptes actrice
emmanuelle dont on vient de parler
hockey mais est ce que le contact racing
électronique ne risque pas de
sérieusement mettre en danger la
protection de données personnelles est
ce que ça ne risque pas d'être un cheval
de troie pour permettre au gouvernement
de se lancer dans la surveillance de
masse ne faut-il pas se méfier des
applications de contact racing est bien
tout dépend de l'application en question
ce qu'il faut surtout éviter c'est de
faire un amalgame entre tous les
algorithmes ce serait de l'algue aurait
mis 6 mhz de l'algorithme de
l'algorithme isme de l'algo malien de
l'algo malka moi ça sonne bien bref ça
serait manquer de discernement entre des
algorithmes pourtant très différents oui
certains algorithmes de contact racing
sont incroyablement invasifs comme très
probablement ceux qui sont utilisés en
chine mais d'autres solutions beaucoup
moins invasif existe et non
essentiellement aucune chance de se
transformer en outil de surveillance de
masse
aujourd'hui en particulier je vais vous
décrire l'une des solutions techniques
les moins invasive à ma connaissance
elle s'appelle dp 3 t et a été conçu par
des chercheurs en informatique de
premier plan en particulier le projet
est porté par l'informaticienne carmela
30 qu'aux professeurs à l'université le
pfl qui travaillent d'ailleurs dans le
bureau à l'étagé juste en dessous du
mien
bon pas aujourd'hui parce que bon
aujourd'hui je suis encore confiné chez
moi mais vous voyez ce que je veux dire
mais il n'y a pas qu'elle comme vous le
voyez le projet implique une véritable
dream team de chercheurs en informatique
avec notamment cinq autres professeurs
de le pfl mathias pailleur jean pierre
ribot marcel salat et jim larus et
edward bugnon ainsi que d'autres
chercheurs de le pfl et d'ailleurs il
honnêtement je suis particulièrement
fier de cette mobilisation
exceptionnelle de l'université depuis le
début de la pandémie
alors comment fonctionne dp 3 t avant
d'en venir là je précise que au moment
où tourner cette vidéo dp3 tenais pas
encore une application c'est plus un
protocole un algorithme abstrait qui
définit comment doivent être programmées
des applications de contact racing
protectrice des données personnelles
on parle de white paper dans le jargon
alors où je me filme le projet est
disponible en open source sur github et
le choeur de l'algorithme le backend est
déjà en place autrement dit n'importe
qui peut relire le code soulever ces
inquiétudes et proposer des
améliorations
on est donc très très très très loin
d'un code opaque
écrit par des agents malicieux dans le
plus grand secret pour piger la
population et instaurant une
surveillance de masse d'autant que
carmela qu'aux est particulièrement
engagée contre la surveillance de masse
comme on a déjà parlé sur zeta bike bref
tp 3t est en cours de développement est
également en cours de test avec
notamment l'armée suisse appelée à
tester des pétro t dans les couloirs de
tf1
l'application sera sans doute bientôt
disponible sur l'apple store et sur le
googleplex tort et on espère bien sûr
que tout sera prêt à l'utilisation
notamment pour la première étape de
déconfinement en suisse le 27 avril
alors malheureusement le protocole dp3 t
reste un peu complexe à expliquer à
cause de nombreux petits détails
techniques
aujourd'hui je vais me contenter d'une
explication grossière pour en illustrer
les aspects les plus critiques
je vais même dire des choses qui sont
pas tout à fait juste même si ces petits
mensonges ne correspond donc à des
détails techniques d'importance mineure
et seront accompagnées de notes et
l'écran par ailleurs je vais décrire la
version du 12 avril du white pipe
pour plus de détails et de précision je
vous invite à lire la dernière version
en date du white paper
ok revenons-en au principe global de dp3
t chaque utilisateur devra télécharger
et exécuter une appli sur son téléphone
si l'utilisateur lance la plupart
première fois le jour tu es alors
l'appli va alors généré une clé secrète
aléatoire appelé script qui y noter skt
tête claire ressemble du charabia disons
03 83 1 ab elle ne sera connue que du
téléphone de l'utilisateur
en tout cas pour l'instant puis chaque
jour cette clé secrète skt sur la mise à
jour en posant skt +1 est égal à h de
skt ou achètent une fonction de hachage
cryptographique public
je vous ai déjà parlé plus en détail des
fonctions de hachage cryptographique et
dans cet épisode avec string theory la
propriété importante de achètent ici le
fait que si vous connaissez ascarat
doute est plus un il est impossible de
calculer ce cas de thé à moins de faire
chauffer des milliards d'ordinateurs
pendant des milliards de milliards
d'années donc en gros si vous connaissez
la clé secrète d'un utilisateur le jour
tu es alors vous pouvez connaître toutes
les clés secret de futurs que
l'utilisateur aura utilisé mais vous ne
connaissez pas ses clés secrètes avant
jour tu es ensuite le jour tu es toutes
les cinq minutes
l'appli de l'utilisateur va utiliser sa
clé secrète skt une autre fonction de
hachage pseudo aléatoires public h prime
pour générer un identifiant éphémère
fédérale1 et des dégâts à ach prime de
skt et de haine ou elle est le énième
créneau de cinq minutes de la journée
l'avantagé d'avoir une fonction de ce
dont aléatoire c'est que l'identifiant
fm rfid paraître a alors parfaitement
aléatoire à tout espions qui voudraient
des anonymisées les données de dp3 t
pendant ces cinq minutes le téléphone de
l'utilisateur va alors émettre un
identifiant éphémère via bluetooth
donc si l'identifiant éphémère est alors
f 19 à ses 3 me téléphonent répète via
les ondes boudoul j'utilise appli dp3 tg
actuellement identifiant éphémère afida
est égal à f 19 à ses 3 j'utilise
l'appli dp3 tg actuellement
l'identifiant éphémère est fidèle et
égale à f 19 à ses 3 j'utilise l'appli
dp3 tg actuellement l'identifiant
éphémère
fidel est égal à f 10,9 à ces trois et
ainsi de suite
bon et discussions entre téléphone ne
vont pas être bien passionnante mais le
but c'est avant tout qu'elle soit utile
sans toutefois révéler quoi que ce soit
de personnel et puis après cinq minutes
le téléphone va changer d'identifiants
éphémère ainsi s'il passe à 35 bd 42
alors il se mettra désormais à répéter
utilise l'api dp3 tg actuellement
l'identifiant éphémère rfid est égal à
35 bd 42 utilise l'api dp3 tg
actuellement l'identifiant éphémère
affidés est égal à 35 bd 42 utilise
l'api dp3 tg actuellement l'identifiant
éphémère affidés est égal à 35 bd 42 et
ainsi de suite pendant cinq minutes
avant de passer ensuite à l'identifiant
éphémère suivant noter qu'un nation qui
ne fera qu écouter les messages en
bluetouff ne pourra alors pas deviner
que les identifiants éphémère est fidèle
et égale à f 19 ac3 et affidés est égal
à 35 bd quarante deux correspondants
fait même téléphone et en particulier à
la même clé secrète skt alors en fait
c'est un peu plus compliqué que cela
mais on en reparle un peu plus tard dans
la vidéo
en plus de parler chaque
disons dp3 teva aussi écouter ainsi si
un téléphone en temps j'utilise applique
dp3 t et j'ai actuellement l'identifiant
éphémère affidés est égal à 1 b 8 des 9
e
alors il va noter en mémoire le fait
qu'il a été en contact avec
l'identifiant éphémère est fidèle et
égale à 1 b 8 des 9 e va aussi noté la
durée du contact avec un b 8 des 9 e et
une estimation de la distance entre les
deux téléphones enfin il va noter une
teinte grossière de rencontre peut-être
par exemple le lundi 11 mai au matin
ainsi au fil des rencontres le téléphone
de chaque utilisateur va se créer une
liste d'identifiants qu'éphémère avec
lequel il est entré en contact
n'oublions pas que l'objectif de cette
liste c'est de pouvoir alerter
l'utilisateur si l'un des ses
identifiants éphémère correspond à un
individu ensuite testé positif à la
crevette 19 mais comment l'utilisateur
est il alors notifiée comment le
téléphone de l'utilisateur
peut-il savoir si l'un des identifiants
éphémère de sa liste correspond à un
individu désormais positif à la coke
vite 19 quai l'algorithme permettent un
tel contact racing ce en violation des
données personnelles
et bien c'est un utilisateur de dp3 t
appelons le pub est testé positif à la
korité 19 alors le téléphone de bob va
alors le signal est un serveur central
et partager sa clé publique s agit du
premier jour j où bob était contagieux
d'après les estimations des autorités
sanitaires
la clé secrète de bob est alors publiés
sur internet par exemple dans un serveur
central dédié à dp 3 t ainsi chaque
joueur s'il ya des milliers de nouveaux
cas positifs par les utilisateurs de dp3
t alors il y aurait des milliers de clés
secrètes skt mises en ligne chaque jour
chaque utilisateur de dp3 teva alors
télécharger toute cette liste de clé
secrète skt considérons en particulier
une utilisatrice
appelons-la alice qui cherchent à savoir
si elle est à risque de lakovic 19 ou
non pour le savoir le jour tu es à
lister charge donc toutes les clefs ce
crédit rendu public avant le jour tu es
ça lui fait donc des clés secrètes
est ce que j avec j inférieur à thé puis
le téléphone d'alice va utiliser les
fonctions de hachage public pour
calculer les clés secrètes des joueurs
suivants jusqu'au jour tu es grâce à
l'équation sk de j puissant est égal à h
2 s agit ainsi que les identifiants
effet
ces clés secrètes via l'équation afida
est égal à h prime de ce que j ai de
haine
ainsi alice dispose d'une liste rouge de
tous les identifiants éphémère associé à
un individu positif à la copie type 19
et elle peut comparer cette liste avec
une veste verte des identifiants
éphémère avec qui elle est entrée en
contact l'intersection entre ces listes
rouges et vertes coassements alors à
l'exposition d'alice à des risques de
contamination
l'appli va ensuite exploiter ces données
pourraient estimer le risque qu alice
est contaminée si ce risque est élevé
s'il est au delà d'un certain seuil
alors alice va recevoir une notification
à la prendra alors qu'elle est à risque
noté que la fonction qui calcule le
risque d individus en fonction du nombre
de contacts à risque de durer de ses
contacts de la date de ces contacts
notamment relativement au jour
d'infection de bob et de la proximité du
contact ne semble pas avoir été décidée
par dp 3 t
cependant il s'agira certainement d'une
fonction open source que chacun pourra
peut-être même adapté en fait cette
fonction pourrait même évoluer avec le
temps en fonction de l'avancée de votre
compréhension et modes de transmission
de lakovic 19
de même le seuil pour envoyer une
notification pourrait évoluer en
fonction des dernières estimations du
taux de reproduction effectif
rt ainsi plus rt est grand plus il
faudra être prudent et 1 600 le bc le
sec pour demander à davantage
d'utilisateurs de se mettre en
quarantaine
quoi qu'il en soit si l'application
signal alice qu'elle est à risque alors
alice pourra se mettre en quarantaine et
contacté les autorités sanitaires
pourraient être testés à son tour à la
colite 10,9 en supposant qu'on disposera
de suffisamment de kits de dépistage à
ce moment là
voilà vous savez tout du protocole
ep 3 t bon peut-être pas tout tout mais
vous connaissez maintenant les grandes
lignes du protocole alors est ce que ça
vous rassure
est ce que ça vous paraît sécuriser ce
protocole peut-il permettre des espions
malveillants y compris le gouvernement
d'effectuer une surveillance de masse en
bref la réponse est non même les
concepteurs de dp3 t ne pourront pas
exploiter le protocole dp3 t pour
apprendre grand chose des initiateurs de
dp3 t en tout cas sur cet aspect la
protection des données personnelles par
dp 3 t est un milliard de fois moins
invasive que des applications comme
google netflix ou kinder que vous
utilisez sur vos téléphones utilisés
facebook même twitter pour se plaindre
des risques de surveillance de dp3 t
c'est ainsi sans doute comparable a
demandé aux passagers autour de vous
d'éteindre leurs lumières pour protéger
l'environnement lors d'un vol
transatlantique
le combat contre la surveillance de
masse semblent avoir des propriétés
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
importante que le contact racing à la
dp3 t en fait tp 3t et justement conçu
pour empêcher cette surveillance de
masse ainsi la protection des données
personnelles de dp3 t est garantie par
le fait que pour les espions et qu'ils
n'ont été en contact avec aucun individu
positif à l'accord et 19
les données publiques correspondent à
une liste de clé secrète qui ressemble à
des nombres aléatoires
dès lors il est très difficile
d'extraire une quelconque information de
ce brouhaha
alors en fait pas tout à fait il ya des
bémols à mettre sur les garanties de
protection des données personnelles de
dp3 t comme l'expliquent le white paper
de dp3 tu es un espion pourrait
installer des antennes un peu partout
pour collecter des identifiants éphémère
il pourrait ensuite croiser les données
ainsi collectées avec les clés secrètes
rendu public
et ils apprendraient ainsi qu'un
individu passé par tel endroit à quelle
heure est désormais positif à la cocaïne
19 du coup si c'est quel type d'individu
passage quel type d'endroit à vers
quelle heure
alors il peut deviner quel individu sont
positifs avec 26,9 de façon plus subtile
et moins coûteuse un espion pourra
cibler une victime
disons par exemple une star en essayant
d'attraper un de ses identifiants
éphémère s'il y parvient
alors il pourra savoir si la star a été
testée positive à la coved 19 ans
regardons s'il existe une clé secrète
rendu public qui correspond à
identifiant éphémère capter cependant la
plus grosse vulnérabilité en termes de
protection des données personnelles
pourraient résider ailleurs elle
pourrait ainsi résider dans les signaux
bluetouff utilisés par nos téléphones
en effet en pratique d'autres
applications de téléphone envoie des
signaux qui identifie le téléphone en
disant par exemple je suis le symptôme
de l'oeil que les écouteurs bluetooth
avec lesquels je suis habituellement
connectés se connecte à moi ainsi mon
téléphone pour être alternée des
messages je suis le samsung de l'est et
j'utilise dp3 thé avec l'identifiant
éphémère 35 b 1 à 2 un espion qui entend
les deux messages en même temps pourra
alors deviner que 35 b 1 à 2 l
identifiant éphémère de l'est et si
l'esprit on voit qu'une clé secrète et
publiée sur le serveur central et est
compatible avec l'identifiant éphémère
35b un aa2 alors laisse monde devineras
que les halak au vide
19 et même si on coupe les autres
applications du téléphone ou si on
modifie ni au téléphone pour qu'il nous
donne plus leur vrai nom via bluetooth
il demeure un risque que des détails
dans le signal envoyé par le téléphone
trahissent l'identité du téléphone un
samsung s 9 en voit ainsi des signaux
bluetouff probablement légèrement
différent des signaux envoyés par un
iphone 10 un espion pour utiliser de
telles informations
pour associer des identifiants éphémère
à des individus bref malgré les efforts
colossaux déployés par la formidable
équipe de dp3 t il serait approximative
de dire que des pétro t est parfaitement
prêt aussi priseur vie cependant
concevoir des systèmes parfait en
informatique est essentiellement un
possible surtout si ces systèmes sont
ensuite utilisées par des utilisateurs
imprudents ou mal informés sur les
détails de la technologie et soyons
honnêtes on est tous très ignorants des
détails de la technologie de téléphone
dès lors il s'agit davantage de se
demander si ces petites faiblesses de
dp3 t justifie le rejet de cette
technologie
sachant que dp3 t pourrait être critique
pour permettre un déconfinement sécurisé
avec un taux de reproduction effectif
certes est inférieur à 1 qui nous
éviterait ainsi d'avoir à recourir un
confinement liberticide dangereux pour
les personnes mal logées où logeait avec
des individus violents est extrêmement
risqué pour notre économie
alors certains semblent craindre de voir
pp droite et se transformait en un outil
de surveillance de masse que l'on soit
clair ce scénario est très improbable
en fait les concepteurs de dp3 t ont
pris soin de l'intérêt petits billets
sécurisés de dp3 t autrement dit
n'importe qui peut quitter dp3 tu es
quand il veut et garantir que dp 3t ne
pourra plus le surveiller en effet tp 3t
est un code entièrement open source qui
s'appuie sur les missions de
l'information par l'utilisateur
avec son consentement si un utilisateur
cessé de transmettre de l'information
il peut simplement désinstaller son
application ainsi les concepteurs de dp3
étaient en usage que lorsque la pandémie
aura disparu par exemple grâce à un
vaccin efficace
dp 3d sera arrêtée alors en pratique
l'interactivité sécurisé de dp3 t n'est
peut-être pas complètement garantie peut
ainsi envisager la possibilité que les
assurances médicales exige l'utilisation
de dp3 t par les utilisateurs et qu'il y
aura des pénalités pour ceux qui ne
l'utilisent pas cependant même là en
tout cas pour le protocole à actuel il
sera possible pour chaque utilisateur de
créer un faux compte pour éviter la
surveillance par les assurances
médicales
étroite et permet de
lisa teur de vraiment contrôler ce que
son téléphone émet comme information ce
qui lui garantit une très bonne
protection des données personnelles en
particulier quand deux utilisateurs
entre en contact
seuls les téléphones des deux
utilisateurs savent qu'il ya eu un
contact
en fait ce contact ne sera même jamais
mise en ligne ou partager publiquement
ainsi personne ne connaît le graphe des
contacts entre identifiant éphémère
voilà qui est génial d'un point de vue
privacy mais qui est peut-être dommage
un point de vue épidémiologique
après toute l'information sur l'ensemble
des contacts entre différents
utilisateurs est une information
critique pour mieux comprendre la
manière dont la pandémie peut se
diffuser
et elle pourrait même permettre
d'estimer le taux de reproduction
effectifs cartes et les concepteurs de
des pétro t ils y ont pensé
ils ont rajouté une fonctionnalité qui
s'y utilisateurs et consent permet le
partage d'une version bruitées des
informations sur les contacts entre un
utilisateur testé positif à la coved 19
et un utilisateur consentants
l'information de l'utilisateur
consentants est alors anonymisées de
telles données peuvent néanmoins être
critique pour aider les épidémiologistes
mieux suivre et comprendre l'avancée de
la pandémie est ainsi recommandé le
renforcement ou la relaxation des
interventions pour réduire le taux de
reproduction effectifs rt et éviter
notamment une résurgence mortelle du
virus
ainsi les données collectées par dp 3t
sont d'une utilité double d'un côté
elles permettent d'identifier les cas
suspects il leur recommander une auto
isolation de l'autre elles aideront à
mieux estimer le fatidique taux de
reproduction effectif
rt et en particulier estimé si celui ci
est probablement inférieure à 1 ou non
si l'estimation de rt par dp 3 t est
inférieur à 1
alors on pourra relâcher des
interventions contraignante et ainsi
peut-être éviter des faillites
d'entreprises et des licenciements dans
le cas contraire si arte semble
supérieur à 1
on pourra renforcer les interventions
comme rappelé l'importance des gestes
barrières ou si arte est très nettement
supérieure à recourir à des clôtures
électronique ou un second confinement
grâce à des p3 t&d alternative atp 3 t
on pourra bien mieux piloter en temps
réel le contrôle de la pandémie
au lieu d'analyser les données de décès
ne nous renseigne que sur la valeur que
rt prônait il y a deux trois ou quatre
semaines
autrement dit dp3 t permet de collecter
des données qui sur le long terme
pourrait sauver beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de vies
alors malheureusement on n'est toujours
pas au bout de nos peines d'un point de
vue sécurité il faut vérifier que les
utilisateurs malveillants ne pourront
pas faire dix fonctionner le système dp3
tu es un risque important est que des
utilisateurs malveillants voudront créer
la panique forcer la mise en quarantaine
de nombreux utilisateurs de dp3 t ou
simplement exprimé leur désaccord envers
le contact précis une façon simple de
pourrir des pétro t serait de créer
toutes sortes de fausses identités
associé à différentes clés secrètes de
communiquer les identifiants éphémère un
maximum d'utilisateurs de dp3 t et puis
de publier les clés secrètes en
prétendant être positif à l'hct avec
vide 19
de nombreux utilisateurs de dp3 t
recevrez alors une fausse alerte
leur demandant de se mettre en
quarantaine pour éviter cela dp 3d
propose que les agences sanitaires
envoie un code à usage unique vous
individus testés positifs dès lors ceux
qui reçoivent un tel code pour envoyer
leur clé secrète accompagner une sorte
de signature électronique
les agences sanitaires qui confirme que
l'individu a effectivement été testé
positif à la cuvette 19 malheureusement
ceci n'empêchera pas d'autres attaques
pour pourrir système en particulier cet
article d'un autre chercheur de le pfl
serge bonnet l'isq d'autres attaques
notamment des attaques par replay ou par
relais qui pourrait nuire au bon
fonctionnement de des pétro t
ces attaques pourraient en effet alerté
inutilement des individus et les appeler
malencontreusement à rester chez eux dès
lors des p3 t pourrait devenir
inefficace voire contre-productive serge
jouannem propose toutefois des solutions
pour contrer ces attaques en s'appuyant
notamment sur des signatures
électroniques
personnellement il s'agit là de ma plus
grosse inquiétude concernant dp3 t je
crains que des utilisateurs malveillants
pourraient réussir à dégrader
significativement l'efficacité de dp
tout raté et ce possiblement avec
relativement peu d'efforts dans le
jargon on parle de résilience des
attaques puissantes in ou pour des
raisons un peu folklorique en appel
byzantins les utilisateurs
potentiellement maximum en nuisible au
système malheureusement il ya une
tension récurrente entre résilience aux
byzantins et protection des données
personnelles
en effet ne ferait selon de contrer les
byzantins consiste justement à
surveiller davantage tout le monde pour
vérifier l'absence de faux comptes par
exemple mais bien sûr en général ceux ci
réduit aussi la protection des données
personnelles dp3 t est il allé trop loin
en faveur de la protection des données
personnelles sur ce compromis
difficile à dire mon impression pour
l'instant est plutôt non sachant que
déployer des attaques à grande échelle
reste tout de même assez coûteux mais je
suis très très loin d'être la personne
n'a pu caler sur ce sujet et je me
trompe peut-être
une autre réserve
la fiabilité de la communication
bluetouff alors malheureusement j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à trouver des
informations fiables sur le sujet selon
les spécifications et semble que les
communications bluetooth notamment en
mode boutou flow bathory peuvent se
faire jusqu'à à 100 mètres de distance
mais ça paraît irréaliste en pratique de
façon fait préoccupante selon cette
source qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut beaucoup
d'applications debout tout flou comme
les écouteurs ont une portée effective
qui est davantage de l'ordre de 6 pouces
soit 15 cm ce qui serait très
insuffisant ceci dit il semble possible
d'améliorer les algorithmes de
reconstruction du signal bluetooth pour
rendre la lecture des messages plus
touffu plus fiables il ya aussi les
risques de faux négatifs par exemple
aussi le signal bluetooth traverse un
mur ou au plafond
alors que le virus n'a aucune chance de
traverser ces barrières physiques la
communication bluetouff pourrait laisser
croire à tort qu'il ya eu un contact à
risque bref il ne faut pas perdre de vue
qu'on parle de là d'une technologie
nouvelle qui n'a jamais été déployés
même si elle paraît très prometteuse il
faut s'attendre à beaucoup de bugs et de
difficultés qui n'ont pas encore été
anticipés notamment concernant son
efficacité c'est pourquoi plutôt que de
tout miser sur une technologie
surtout à l'heure actuelle il me semble
important que d'autres équipes de
recherche de développement travaille sur
d'autres pistes possiblement plus
efficace technologique ou non même si
ces autres pistes risquent également
être plus invasive il semble important
de nous préparer à toutes sortes de
réponses à toutes sortes de scénarios
futurs même si beaucoup de ses efforts
de préparation paraîtront inutile une
fois qu'on en saura plus c'est
finalement ça le safety 27 s'est préparé
des plans et des technologies qui en
général ne seront jamais utilisés
il ya une critique
la version originale de début trotter
qui vient du fait que des baies 3 tu es
obligé d'individus infectés a révélé
tous ses identifiants éphémère
postérieure au moment où il devient
contagieux voilà qui pourrait permettre
un individu en contact avec l'individu
infectés de noter des régularité dans
ses contacts avec les individus infectés
et ainsi de peut-être deviné que en plus
de le voir tous les jours au bureau
l'individu infecté est aussi tous les
soirs dans le même lieu disons d'art
moderne
je vous laisse imaginer des versions
plus cocasses ou plus problématique et
de ce genre de découverte
pour éviter cela la dp3 et et propose
une variante appelé design 2 bon on est
encore à l'étape de la recherche des
meilleurs protocole les noms un peu plus
sexy de protocoles attendront un peu
dans ce design 2 les personnes testées
positives peuvent choisir de révéler
uniquement une partie de leurs
identifiants éphémère d'un autre
avantage tout cette méthode c'est que
chaque utilisateur ne peut plus déduire
de continuité des identifiants éphémère
auquel il a été exposé ainsi s'il voit
qu'il a été exposé en parlant aux
identifiants éphémère f à 315 à et 96 bd
1a
il n'est pas capable de déterminer si
ces deux identifiants correspondent à la
même personne
enfin un dernier avantage cette mise à
jour c'est d'empêcher un espion de
télécharger facilement les identifiants
éphémère d'individus contagieux en
remplaçant la liste de ses identifiants
éphémère par une structure de données
probabiliste appelé filtre de coucou
coucou comme l'oiseau pas comme bonjour
mais c'est à voir avec le fait que les
coucous n'hésite pas à pousser d'autres
aux yeux de laure ni pour avoir toute
l'attention de leur mère à la nature
c'est beau la nature bon bref je m'égare
téléchargeant tout le filtre de coucou à
l'iss peut vérifier si un identifiant de
sa liste verte de contact appartient au
filtre de coucou le filtre de coucou
permet de vérifier facilement la
présence d'un identifiant éphémère dans
le filtre cependant il empêche tout
utilisateur malveillant de lister tous
les identifiants éphémère de la liste
car ceux ci sont en quelque sorte masqué
par le filtre de coucou le problème de
cette solution toutefois c'est qu'elle
demande de communiquer beaucoup plus
d'informations oui parce que cette fois
ci un utilisateur et testés positifs et
veut partager cinq jours de compétition
à raison d'un nouvel identifiant
éphémère toutes les cinq minutes
ça nous fait cinq points 24 x 70 / 5
soit des milliers
d'identifiant et éphémère à partager à
raison de dizaines de milliers de
nouveaux infectés par jour ça nous fait
là des centaines de mégaoctets à
télécharger pour chaque utilisateur de
dp3 thé par jour et donc 3 gigaoctets
par mois
bon il s'agit là d'un pires cas et ça
commence à être très contraignant
une autre mesure ajouté
consiste à s'appuyer sur le secret
répartis pour empêcher l'espionnage à
distance en particulier l'espionnage à
distance des messages bluetouff permet
un espion d'entendre des bouts de phrase
dite par nos téléphones
le problème c'est qu'il est possible que
ces bouts de phrases finissent par
correspondre à l'identifiant éphémère
surtout si les téléphones ne font que
répéter cet identifiant éphémère
l'astuce pour éviter cela consiste à
faire en sorte que pendant les cinq
minutes ou un téléphone un identifiant
éphémère donné le téléphone émet en
bouffe des indices de son identifiant
éphémère dont s'appuyant sur une
technique appelée secret répartie il
peut garantir que toute personne qui
écoute sera capable de reconstruire
l'identifiant éphémère si et seulement
si la personne n'arrive à entendre car
indices différents ainsi plus qu'à est
grand plus il sera difficile pour
l'espion de reconstruire l'identifiant
éphémère et plus le système sera
confidentiel mais plus qu'à écran plus
il sera également difficile pour un
individu proche de reconstruire
l'identifiant éphémère lui aussi et on
pourrait ainsi loupé des contacts bref
il ya là encore un bon compromis à
trouver entre efficacité du contact
racing et protection des données
personnelles
j'ai aussi lu mentionné par ci par là
des idées de signature électronique pour
nous permettre l'enregistrement que des
contacts avec qui il ya eu un échange
d'identifiants éphémère et non pas
uniquement une communication
unidirectionnelle d'identifiants
éphémère ceci pourrait éviter
l'espionnage par écoute seulement mais
il forcera aussi chaque utilisateur de
dp3 t a certifié indirectement plus de
choses quant à sa position à différents
moments de la journée
quoi qu'il en soit cette proposition
n'est pas dans la version de dp3 t du 12
avril
bref selon j'espère vous avoir surtout
convaincu aujourd'hui c'est que de
nombreux chercheurs prennent très au
sérieux le problème de la protection des
données personnelles et on déployait
l'état de l'art en sécurité et en prize
aussi pour concevoir des applications
néanmoins efficace pour le contact
racing ainsi ont-ils consulter p 3 t de
solutions de contacts racing ultra
bright aussi préservé malheureusement
même dp3 t est loin d'être parfaite
aucune solution ne sera il n'y a pas de
plan pour revenir à la normale dp3 t16
de légères faille de prat v6 dont
certaines ne semble pas si spécifique à
des pétro t ainsi que des failles
peut-être plus préoccupante de
robustesse à des utilisateurs
malveillants et peut-être aussi
d'efficacité du bluetooth l'adoption
massive de dp3 t réduirait probablement
de façon importante le taux de
reproduction effectif rt mais le réduire
at il suffisamment en fait vu
l'incertitude énorme sur la valeur que
prendra le taux de reproduction effectif
rt pendant le déconfinement ainsi que
l'incertitude sur l'efficacité de dp3 t
il semble préférable d'envisager toutes
sortes de solutions technologiques ou
non pour permettre le contact racing et
garder arte en dessous de 1
y compris peut-être des solutions plus
intrusive que dp 3 t oui car après tout
plutôt que d'exiger des solutions
parfaites il semble que sia de ne pas
perdre de vue qu'on a avant tout devant
nous des balances coûts-bénéfices à
effectuer quel compromis trouvé entre
protection des données personnelles
les protection de la santé publique
ainsi que de la sécurité économique de
millions de précaires et d'individus mal
lotis en particulier que rajoute ou
enlèvent dp3 t ou d'autres solutions de
contacts racing par rapport au statu quo
où rien n'est utilisé à cela se rajoute
une difficulté supplémentaire
on l'a vu l'efficacité du contact racing
et quadratique ans au nombre
d'utilisateurs 40 hier son adoption
massive est vraiment critique mais ce
n'est pas tout il est probable que
différents protocoles de contact racing
ne seront pas compatibles
taylor 6 30 % des utilisateurs utilisent
le protocole x et que 30 % utilisent y
est si xy ne sont pas compatibles alors
seulement 18% des contacts seront
enregistrées par opposition si 60% de la
population utilise x alors 36 % des
contacts seront enregistrées la
coordination sur le choix de
l'application peut ainsi doubler
l'efficacité du contact racing
il est donc crucial qu'on parvienne à se
mettre d'accord sur quel protocole de
contact racing utilisés y compris si
celui qui sera finalement utilisé ne
satisfait pas toutes nos exigences
éthiques
enfin pour en revenir aux primes de
protection des données personnelles
il est crucial de réussite et sur le
fait qu'il semble évident que dp3 t en
particulier n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
par rapport à toute l'information est
extraite de téléphone par les géants du
web comme google facebook amazon ou
autres tender dans ce contexte adopté
dp3 t ne semble finalement pas vraiment
augmenté la violation des données
personnelles
en tout cas si vous utilisez certains de
ses autres services sachant tout cela la
balance coûts bénéfices d'une promotion
d'une adoption massive de dp3 t ne
semble pencher très nettement en faveur
de dp 3d ou des alternatives de débutera
dès qu'ils seraient aussi bien aux
meilleurs le taux de reproduction
effective rt en dépend fortement
or le futur de nos sociétés semble
lui-même dépendre énormément de ce
nombre